-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-Well, I always said
you make a great case.
-You know, I saw you
debating DeSantis.
-Yeah.
And I said, you know,
I'm trying to get this guy
to run for president
for a long time. (LAUGHS)
He looks like
he'd be very good at it.
What I like with that also,
is that you're kind of mean,
-and we need that.
-(LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-And, you know, when you need
to be not over the top.
-But I was on--
-GAVIN NEWSOM:
No, I appreciate that.
-I was on KBLA.
-GAVIN: Yeah.
The other day-- yesterday,
with my friend Tavis Smiley.
-I'm an investor and a supporter
of that station.
-GAVIN: Yeah. Yeah.
And I-- You know, he said,
"Who do you want to run
for the president?"
I mentioned I think
you'd be good at the job,
not this year we know.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-(CHUCKLES)
No, I know. Um... (CHUCKLES)
But he said,
"I don't think he could win.
I don't think he could win.
He's too progressive.
-GAVIN: Yeah.
-Coming from this state,
and what he's done in this state
to win in any Southern state,
any red state."
I disagreed, but--
Now, this is a progressive,
African-American owned station,
-and...
-GAVIN: Yeah.
...I'm sure they like you,
but he doesn't think
you can win.
What do you say to that?
When you-- When your--
If you could win the--
Look at the... the...
the, uh, Swing states.
-There's only eight of them.
-GAVIN: Right.
Well, I mean, California
is an interesting case study,
isn't it?
It's the size
of 21-state populations
combined.
BILL MAHER: Yeah.
Two-thirds of the state
is very deeply red.
We don't need to be lectured
on rural, politics
or border issues.
I mean, in so many ways,
these are familiar issues.
And those issues
of the heartland
of the United States
are very much a part and parcel
of the work we're doing
in this state.
But look,
I understand this notion
that you're from the coast,
you don't understand
those things.
You can't talk the language,
you're not able to communicate.
-BILL: Well--
-Uh, you're not able to
actually encourage
-and find that common ground.
-No, it's stuff like
there's a new law in this st--
I think we have
way too many regulations
and laws,
as we've talked about,
and this one, I think, says,
"If you're a department store
with over 500 employees,
-you have to have
a gender-neutral...
-GAVIN: Oh, the toys.
-...toy department.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-BILL: Stuff like that...
-Yeah, I get it.
-So, do you think that's silly?
-GAVIN: No,
but it's interesting.
-BILL: You think that's
a silly thing that we have...
-What was interesting--
BILL: ...too much government...
too much government there.
That-- Look,
that's an interesting one,
because the department stores
came to us supporting that.
And they were once
making a case for that.
They were making us--
They're already moving
in that direction.
BILL: They wanted you
to make a law about them?
Well, they--
But they've supported
the legislation.
Wasn't legislation
that was enacted,
that was initiated
from my office,
but it was legislation
that came up
with interesting support
from the industry itself.
But I understand
how that's exploited,
and good people can disagree.
But that's not something
we woke up and said,
"This is a top priority
for the state,"
when we know that
the top priorities are
homelessness, housing,
the issues of crime,
quality of life,
and issues
related to regulation and taxes,
which are all top of mind.
-But I get how those things
are weaponized.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
All right.
So... While I got you here...
-(GAVIN CHUCKLES)
-...'cause I live here,
-and I'm not going anywhere.
-(CHUCKLES)
So, I just want to make this
a better state
-like everybody else.
-GAVIN: Amen.
And good job,
this year, making it rain.
-GAVIN: You're welcome.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-That was uh...
-That was so...
-Yeah.
-Because--
That was
my legislative priority.
-Yes. Yeah.
-(LAUGHS) It was-- It was
looking bad there for a while,
and we still
don't have enough water
-in the Colorado River
and all this stuff.
-GAVIN: Yeah.
And then, whenever I read,
80 percent of the water
goes to agriculture.
-Almonds.
-GAVIN: Right.
No one ever asked you
about almonds?
Oh, I'm gonna ask you
about almonds.
-(LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-We grow a boatload of almonds.
-GAVIN: I'm well aware.
You know what,
you know how much-- How many--
-How much water it takes to--
-GAVIN: Many gallons.
-Nineteen hundred gallons
to grow a pound of almonds.
-Yeah.
We-- Come on, man.
-(GAVIN LAUGHING)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-BILL: Take on big almonds.
-(LAUGHS) Take on big almonds.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
I mean, it's not like
we don't have the water.
-GAVIN: No. But...
-But--
(HESITATES)
You're right about this.
It's not that we don't have
the water that said.
You know, the last couple years
were tough.
I mean, it's-- But it's also
where the water is falling,
and we're not capturing it.
And we're not capturing
those extreme years
with these atmospheric rivers.
Wets are getting a lot wetter,
dry is drier,
hots are getting a lot hotter.
And so, we've got to modernize
our conveyance system,
we've got to modernize
our storage,
not just above ground
but below ground.
And so, that's a big part
of our focus and frame,
including desalinization plants.
We have 20 projects
just on desal
that we're working on today,
so we've been--
We put out
a detailed water strategy
that includes-- By the way,
getting that
Delta conveyance project
back up and operational,
and includes the first
above ground off-stream
storage facility
in half a century in the state,
which, by the way,
is being aided
by a regulatory package
I pushed forward
to reduce red tape
in the state of California,
address the permitting quagmires
that you rightfully pointed out.
(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-See you're... (LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
You're good at this.
-What... (LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
BILL: See, I'm telling you,
you're good at this job.
-Okay, but-- (LAUGHS)
No, sit down. Okay, but--
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
But here's anot--
I feel like
the last couple of years,
you've, like,
purposefully picked this fight
with the red states.
-I mean, the DeSantis--
-Yeah.
Yeah, but I don't wanna live
in the Civil War country.
-GAVIN: I agree with that.
-You know what?
-GAVIN: I--
-But you seem like,
you purposely wanna set up
this... this dichotomy between--
Oh, this is a blue state,
and that's a red state,
-and I don't wanna live
in that country.
-I love that.
BILL: I like Florida.
-I'm with you, and by the way,
I like Florida as well.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Like-- I like all these states.
I completely agree.
I don't wanna
have a state of mind
that's in constant
fight-or-flight.
We've gone through so much.
We've been
polarized and traumatized.
This has been
a tough five, six years
across the globe,
not just in this country.
That said, I'm not gonna
sit back and watch,
and you made the point
just a moment ago
in your monologue.
You got folks out there,
trying to bring us back
to a pre-1960s world.
America in reverse.
Rolling back voting rights,
LGBTQ rights, women's rights,
not just access to abortion,
but contraception.
I mean, it's a profound
and consequential moment.
And you could sit by and say,
"Well,
I really wanna get along,"
as these guys
are rolling back the clock.
Or you can stand tall
and assert yourself.
And the reason I started to go
into those red states,
the reason
I started to take on DeSantis,
and the reason
I started doing ads
in these red states
is I didn't feel
my party was doing enough.
It was CRT, one year,
then it's ESG, and it's DEI,
anything with three letters,
these guys keep coming.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-And they're shape-shifting.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-And they're-- I mean,
they're char-- And, so...
But it's true, right.
And so... And I just thought
there was a little timidity
in our party.
And I thought
we need to call this stuff out.
These guys are being
on a banning binge
across this country.
You want to talk
about cancel culture,
look at the Republican Party.
Ask Bud Light, target Disney.
That's just the private sector.
Banning speech
is not just in the classroom,
but in the boardroom
as it relates to issues of race.
Look what they've done,
3,362 books just last year.
They're banning.
This is a serious
and consequential moment.
It's the cultural purge
that's going on in this country
And so, I just felt like
we needed to call that out
as democrats,
and put them on the defensive,
since we're consistently
on our heels
as a Democratic party.
Even though I think
the facts bear out our case
-significantly better
than the case on the other side.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
But again, Bill, I say all that
with love in my heart...
-(LAUGHS)
-...with love in my heart,
and I mean that, I mean,
I don't talk down to people...
-BILL: Can you-- (CLEARS THROAT)
-...I don't wanna talk
past people.
Everyone wants to be respected,
connected and protected,
and we all want to be loved
and need to be loved.
I'm with you on all that.
At the same time, man,
when you're going after
the LGBT community
and talking down to people
and humiliating folks,
you're threatening to sue
the special Olympians,
when you're going after
the Black community
and trying to rewrite history
and saying slavery somehow
was some workforce
development program,
-damn it, we have to call
that stuff out.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
(CHUCKLES) Okay.
-GAVIN: Off of my high horse.
-Oh, you were.
-Can you teach that speech
to Biden?
-(GAVIN CHUCKLES)